vaynernation what's good i'm pretty
excited about this podcast um as many of
you know who listen i'm obsessed with
the concept of what the utility is in an
nft
uh i'm obsessed with good
entrepreneurship
people that are patient and build the
right way
i'm so i'm obsessed with andy k not
making noise in the background
but i do love that you're sitting on the
floor my man from the dirt um we're here
with one of my favorite entrepreneurs
i'm going to let him introduce himself
and and why i say my favorite we've had
some opportunities to chop up in miami
and other places but i like really
watching from afar and i really do
admire true operations you know there's
people with ideas that are creative
there's there's all sorts of versions um
i'm such an operator and i've been my
whole life i know that most people don't
see me that way because i put out a lot
of sizzle into the world with the way i
communicate but for me it's always been
about the stake it's why i'm always
confident it's why i always win
it's why v friends will win it's why
vayner wins it's why wine library wins
it's why everything wins if you can
really operate truly the hr stuff the
balancing your checkbook like real [ __ ]
like actually running a business and
it's also why i give so much love to
like small businesses like the people my
messages and dms that they're like yo
i'm no big deal but like people you know
people i i hate this i always have to
reply like you are big deal you know i'm
no big deal but like i got two bakeries
in detroit and it's going well i'm doing
two million i'm every time i'm like do
you understand how hard it is to run two
[ __ ] bakeries in detroit that does
two million dollars in revenue your
[ __ ] champion stop reading the
[ __ ] occasional headlines of like the
crazy money made by the one percent of
the one percent of the one percent now
this dude is building real [ __ ]
business he's not necessarily a bakery
in detroit but
a bakery in detroit could be the name of
a song that's played at one of his
concerts
t why don't you introduce yourself fully
uh
and then we'll go into the building of
rolling loud which is one of the most
culturally relevant
uh events in the world and then we'll go
into kind of a a quick like punch line
of this utility that i'm very excited
you're letting me kind of break it out
there a little give a little awareness
to yeah i'm excited to tell people about
it but my name is tarik sharif as you
know but what's up garyvee universe and
uh i'm the co-founder co-ceo of rolling
loud uh rolling loud festival and media
and merch and all that it's uh it's been
a journey you know we started rolling
out in 2015 but prior to that we had
what i call our college tuition of
throwing regular concerts from 2010 to
2015 just building up our cutting our
teeth from 100 person shows 500 700 000.
what was the first show
rick ross after party chubby's nightclub
tallahassee florida
um he was performing at famu homecoming
with dj khaled and waka
a couple other people
and i was hit his his sister he tweeted
for for after party bookings
email ricky rosay bookings at gmail so
that i was like oh this is it this is it
first of all like i didn't want to do
after parties i want to do concerts but
then i saw that opportunity grabbed it
long story short we're not after party
promoters we're concert promoters we
learned that that night
we took a fat l i love that you i love
the humility
tell them tell the kids at home like
they see rolling loud now they don't
know
that your first event was a big [ __ ]
fat oh dog [ __ ] l yeah 2 000 person
nightclub maybe 200 people there and i'm
being generous when i say 200. like
maybe 67. yes 67 sounds about right you
know uh
not rick ross's fault just the promoter
for the after party booked the only
other nightclub in the college town of
tallahassee florida and just out
promoted us yeah and they had the
leverage of having the bigger event to
funnel people from
was rose bad at you guys nah he was the
coolest guy ever he had a contractual
obligation to perform zero songs and he
performed like nine
so it was awesome good for him we had a
great day together [ __ ] out of that kind
of thing he
loved to him forever of course but yeah
because that could have been a real sour
taste
it was you know it was sour and one way
but on top of that if the star comes in
and shits on you for an hour and a half
that's right that just compounds the
[ __ ] out of it nah he was super cool
about it like he he was awesome um but
we learned that night yo we're not after
party promoters let's go back to you
retired real quick from that yeah
it's just we wanted to throw concerts
you know at the time nobody was doing
hip-hop concerts for the type of rappers
we were listening to at the time which
was like currency wiz khalifa mac miller
well you're sean 2010.
so like hip-hop at lunch days big shout
out my boys yeah
so we just went back to that plan by
february 20th
that's pre-sound cloud right yeah that's
like right because i'm thinking you do
you know do you know that do you even
know boyd that like i was one of the
first 10 people to download soundcloud
alex came up to me at la webb
2011 or 12 the same weekend in paris
when garrett camp in a hotel room with a
couple bottles of bourbon pitched the
idea of uber i was in the [ __ ] room
wow travis was in the room
garrett literally in the room hey guys
i've been thinking about something with
the iphone imagine if you could get a
limo
from your iphone amazing so i always
think about that that happened that
weekend in paris
i downloaded soundcloud and like
anyway nonetheless pre-soundcloud that
crew the stuff boyd was [ __ ] with
stuff that was popping even mice that
was
yeah tailing mice no yeah currency and
wiz met on myspace you know the whole
house how fly that whole era was the oh
geez
yeah yeah so you want to we saw that on
the internet yeah and i knew that if we
booked those rappers you knew because
you saw the [ __ ] wall
yeah you saw the top eight yeah all that
i didn't even have a myspace but i knew
how to navigate it yeah and i and
youtube was popping like i just was
watching what was happening on the
internet facebook at you always preach
about facebook ads like for the past
years i know now it's the roi is
different yeah i still use them though
but facebook ads are back to being a
fairly good deal because ios 14 5 [ __ ]
up all the retargeting dtc brands and a
lot of the money's out of the system and
a lot of other people don't realize how
much is going on there facebook reels
for me is on fire
the facebook reels champion so we're
killing the 67 year olds in iowa in
florida we were some of the first people
doing facebook ads especially for events
but we were i we got a lot of value
there i was reaching the whole state of
wiz khalifa fans were cheap like super
shocking yeah so
just until you built yeah bit did that
for years and then we started seeing
like you know there's a different sub
genre as a rap yes they start seeing the
same fans at the shows
catering to the different subgenres you
got the lyrical fans you got the turnt
up fans you got the melodic fans and
then as you said about soundcloud
soundcloud starts popping up all these
florida artists are like carrying the
torch for soundcloud we're a florida
company so as x and ski
and x's xxx
ski master slump god little pump smoke
perp rob banks raider clan all that
stuff was
with uh we grew together yes so we're
seeing all these
same fans and we're seeing like coming
up with these artists we're like we need
to build
some one event that all of these what
was the first event that you kind of
like when you two actually give give
some love to your partner matt's english
that's my partner him and i have been
we've been friends since fourth grade um
and we used to throw him him myself and
a couple of our other high school
friends we used to throw parties at my
grandma's house i kind of feel bad for
those other friends who were like [ __ ]
man we should have been in the mix nah
those are still my boys like they're
crushing it and they're getting one
when you were like that like when it was
over 2 3 4 a.m or sunday afternoon i
don't know the details but like when you
really had a second to take a beat and
you got it looked at each other and said
oh we got something
honestly it was until the third year of
rolling loud okay like
well maybe the second year the second
year was like i think we got something
but the first year did what first year
was 6 500 people which is already a real
number yeah one day
one one you know one ticket one day 6
500 people 2015 and you were pumped yeah
lost 100 grand but like pumped like hey
never happier to lose a hundo because
you kind of felt like we could build on
yeah we i was like i knew we could build
on your two um year two scaled up to two
days fifteen thousand people per day
and we made back the hundred grand we
lost plus a little bit more so i was
like okay
i think we got something right you and
you felt that your yeah was gonna be
when it happened and then year three we
moved to bayfront park which is where
they do ultra music festival in miami
and we scaled up to 40 000 people per
day for three days so 120 000 over the
weekend um and it the city tried to shut
us down
like we had to have a vote and we
threatened to sue the city for 30
million and all this stuff
it's a city-owned park long so short
they let us through the event and we
sold it out 40 000 a day and the whole
that was when the whole industry was
like whoa what is rolling loud and at
the same time
like i said xxx
look at me is going crazy
like all the me i remember yeah i
remember everything was happening at
once
and people started being like damn what
is wrong and loud like how they how they
strike
and what was happening were you guys
just building community on the web it
was just happening
we were doing shows every month for five
years winning losing and breaking even
with every rapper and every single yeah
the relationship with the youtubers and
the guys that now yeah like we take you
from 200 cap venue on your first tour
your next tour bringing you to 500 your
next tour bringing you a thousand and
then it was like hey the next play is
these festivals we got so it was just a
lot of groundwork yeah the minor leagues
yeah and then yeah you're right yeah
it's almost like wrestling you did the
little shows in like arkansas and then
you had your wrestlemania each year
yeah so that that's basically what it
was and uh with especially with the
online yeah we were always cognizant of
building community online yeah i noticed
that's how i so real quick because i
know we don't have unlimited time and
that's on me i apologize got caught up
in my kid's school um
for the people at home which there's
gonna be a i have such a
all over the [ __ ] place community for
the people at home
rolling loud today as an events business
obviously throughout the merch and it's
a no question lifestyle brand but at its
core no different than vayner x has a
lot of companies but vaynermedia sits at
the middle
rolling loud as an advanced business
just explain to everybody the size and
scale that you've now gotten to
so our miami show does 85 000 people per
day
um we are all over the world once a year
once so we're once anywhere we go over
once a year so we do miami in 2022 you
did miami
portugal netherlands new york and we
would usually do la but we've shifted la
from december to march now got it so you
got it it's not happening this year it's
happening in march why'd you do that
if you were able to move to sofi stadium
slash hollywood park that's this
beautiful new venue and obviously
december when you have two nfl teams as
you know a lot about the nfl they got
you know the chargers i'm still turned
up from the jets stunner on sunday
everything
receipts [ __ ] by the way the
funniest thing is i'm so deep in jet's
culture
when i did that
all day monday which is a couple days
ago when we're filming this everyone's
like what the [ __ ] did that mean i
forgot that nobody really follows the
jets like that and our head coach was
saying earlier in the week that he's
keeping receipts of everyone who says we
suck and so that's what that was but
everybody basically like all my friends
i got hit up more about that piece of
content than anything because a lot of
people just think i lost my mind
anyway so
all those city like yes it's a real
business yeah it's like every festival's
got at least well some of them gotta go
as low as like what do you think for 23.
you got march in la are you're adding
marching because now we're kind of
getting closer to a post-covered world
you're probably feeling a little bit
better because 22 you still had to take
some risks yeah even we were the first
festival back in 21 by the way um which
was a massive risk but we took it and it
worked nobody died of cove so nobody
died at all which is which is shocking
i watched the videos
um
but it it's been it's been just
incredible the support but so 2023 we
got
my uh
la and march then we're going to europe
and end of june beginning in july we've
got ned i like i like how you're doing
oh wait hold up we got thailand and
april thailand skip thailand yeah that's
our first year in asia so uh we've done
like a small show in asia but this is
our first festival in asia we're gonna
be bringing american artists booking
asian artists as well tires um so then
after april we go to end of june top of
july we got europe portugal netherlands
and
we're going to be adding one market that
we haven't announced yet and then we go
to miami then we go to toronto then we
go to which we did this year toronto two
weeks ago then we go to new york
and that's the year good for you my man
all right you know
we've known each other for a minute i've
been wanting to get you on the podcast
more from the entrepreneurial story
because there's so many kids up in my dm
about events businesses i still believe
event businesses are like some of the
best things kids can be building
it a lot of kids do get into it because
a lot of people [ __ ] up because they're
doing it just a party that never start a
business because you want to [ __ ] around
that just go [ __ ] around and pay for it
because those things go into business
100 000
but
um
when you hit me up not too long ago
about what you were thinking i've been
looking see i love this nft winter
because this is where operators really
shine i always think about 2001 234
of the internet because that's when
flickr was built which was really the
precursor to instagram
digg.com
you know read it like i
i was really in the mix in o2
all the blogging which really started
the whole content era myspace
friendster before that like all of it
all the good [ __ ] happened that we all
trade on now new brands but the concepts
were built on the internet post the
crash of the internet stocks i think the
concepts that everyone's gonna play on
on the blockchain people still don't
even realize that there's a blockchain
which is different than the internet
that the nft infrastructure that might
not even be called nfts just like we
don't call
the internet the web anymore but that's
what we used to call we might change the
name but the technology is real and i
believe all the real building starts now
in 23 24 25 the things that are built
will be what really dominates in 29 30
31
and so i'm watching very carefully
because i can't just keep saying well
it's me and v friends i need other
examples and
i believe what what you've got cooked up
is going to be replicated i even got
into the events business my damn self
with v-con because of it
and so would love to talk to you about
what you've got brewing to give people
the preview and for everyone who's
listening
this is why i love
what i do
it's what i love about how you guys roll
from afar i watch you give love to other
things
what what you're about to hear
a lot of you follow me so you know i
came from nft project that gave you
access to event
this is one of the most significant
culturally relevant event businesses in
the world bringing nft utility back into
it and i think it will be replicated by
all of their contemporaries the i know
there's the big country music festival
versions there's you know coachellas and
bonds all this stuff so what do you what
are you all doing
so
i've seen some festivals have put out
some nfts here and there or whatnot and
to your point about like the bear market
or whatever we've been watching and
playing and investigating and investing
in nfts since they came out right with
the whole gold russia nfts but we didn't
want to be perceived as rushing into
that's right just doing a cash grab and
just yep when we weren't even ready so
we buckled down and really worked on
what it is we're doing but essentially
what we're doing is you guys just heard
all the markets we're in
we're we're creating a lifetime pass and
our nft is called loud punks
um punk punks loud punks is a character
of ours already it's at all of our
festivals inflated 40 feet in the air
all of our videos all our ticket
packages always was called loud punk
yeah loud punks p-u-n-x always yeah
pre-crypto punk type of 220. we actually
added the loud in front of punks because
we realized oh people are going to think
we're like copying
uh that's people obviously
yeah but um like we had punk stage yep
i'm aware i'm just doing it people
listening at home
it's called loud punks but basically
it's a connection a collection of nfts a
pfp project essentially
all of which are unique and every single
one gets you lifetime access to any
rolling cloud
period then on top of that there will be
certain trait based utility
which your collection is all about that
yes so we have elements of that trait
based utility where
you know certain or certain ones are
going to give you vip and certain ones
are going to give you access to our
our night club that's at the festival do
people
is that of
available info or you're going to be
announcing that in the coming weeks
the utility aspect the utility is like
out there we haven't told like so where
do people like
this one knowing my audience is going to
have some attention so where should
people go if they want to dig deeper i'd
say follow the twitter at loud punks nft
and join the discord and one more time
on
l-o-u-d-p-u-n-x
nft got you um what do you follow
rolling loud too just on that outside
probably right
um what uh what excites you most about
the project
the idea that it's two things right the
idea that a fan could make this one
investment with us and go to as many
shows as they want and then and then
flip it yeah and make a profit so save
money on the front end of like oh i know
i want to go to three festivals next
year or i know i want to go to three
festivals over the next two years right
or six festivals or whatever it is or
i'm 17 right now making some paper
flipping or doing that but i i know i'm
gonna do this for seven ten years i mean
that's the 16 17 18 year old that's
about this life that's listening they
really
you know the 29 year old that's like man
i'm gonna start settling down not sure
how many i'm gonna go to they don't
realize that you actually re-up in your
late 30s you're like [ __ ] i don't
want to give up on my youth but you'll
learn that soon but you know it's really
interesting where people are in their
life cycle and interest graph and
location right like if you're in new
york right you got new york you got
toronto you got miami that's easy on
that you know that's three right there
yeah and if you got a little paper then
you can go to la then you can go to
europe in the summer like it gets real
interesting real fast exactly and then
this so that's one that's the one and
then the second thing is rolling loud
has always been about building community
and representing different like
subgenres of communities right so this
idea that we could build this community
of our most core fans as well as just
you know celebrity bringing in the nft
community as well
because that was a strength of yours
right there were so many micro
subcultures
of hip-hop if you're like really in it
that you really wouldn't understand you
referenced it earlier
you kind of brought a lot of the most
contemporary ones that you all bet felt
were coming up and then some of the
artists started creating some of these
sub genres
you just see the nft community that
loves this kind of music just being
another sub genre of the overall genre
exactly i think you're all about culture
i'm the same way like culture drives
everything like everything there is
nothing else yeah everything in life is
culture based
we are what do you what do all i'm sorry
interrupt what do you all think religion
is
culture a hundred percent people get it
twisted because it's mature but it's all
the same [ __ ] the [ __ ] do you think fans
are mm-hmm
the jets are a subculture
i hate buffalo
like [ __ ] hate
on some like let's go to war [ __ ] i
understand why countries go to war
i hate josh allen on the record wait do
the jets hate the dolphins yes yeah
that's what i thought and that's my
business and i hate him i tell him all
the time i hate you
i was mad i was mad they won this
weekend when when the ravens were up
35-14 i was like let's [ __ ] go
they're my they're in my division i
don't [ __ ] with people in my division
yeah that's funny um
damn what was i saying i can't believe i
just did a whole i hate rant and didn't
make me mention the patriots we
mentioned the bills and the dolphins boy
have the seasons changed after 20 years
that's the best disa ball [ __ ] boston
you're not even relevant enough to hate
right now that's how much you're [ __ ]
up
just eliminating fans by the second
let me tell you something in chicago
they respect you for it because they're
like yo he's he's a wrestler and i by
the way i posted something the other day
about this guy rolled up on me he was a
patriots fan and all the pap fans in the
comments are like yo [ __ ] that guy's
another like i respect die hard fans are
everything to me yeah like i'm a
die-hard so even though i might dislike
the team that someone's a die-hard up if
you're a true die-hard what i don't like
is bandwagon yeah i don't see as many
[ __ ] patriot jerseys running around
new york as i did four years ago where
the [ __ ] are you bandwagons that's [ __ ]
oh weird you're wearing a bill's jersey
oh weird you're got a ram spot where all
the [ __ ] cavalier jerseys at like i
hate
miami heat games all season and i pay to
sit courtside and it's not that
expensive during the season because it's
miami's boom the playoffs come
everybody it's like oh sorry the tickets
are usually by like khalid bottom i'm
like
sorry i love you kyle kyle didn't go to
one game all regular season
miami's a tricky sports town miami fan
base is not like miami's a tough place
to play for there's just too much other
[ __ ] going on like miami's also got a
lot of transplants like you go to a jets
dolphins game half the stadium jet vans
so miami's gotta especially now even
more in new york oh yeah more new
yorkers live down there so like i'm
gonna see that i need to see a jets game
at hard rock stadium i've gone many
times but this year though like this
year it's like i think it's in december
i mean i'm worried about miami miami
looks real good all right before i gotta
go and we're talking about [ __ ]
sports let's finish this up so those are
two things that really stand out what um
yeah just the thought of like we're
gonna have loud punks lounges at the at
ho soon all the shows but at first
select shows and you know it's just this
idea that like people that are investing
in something together these nfts can
then meet each other in real life link
up
you know i just think that's going to be
incredible
um
we're going to get you back in q1 of
next year we'll find out how the
project's going to find out how the
business is going because i don't like
that we ran out of time and i've got to
run and i think we got a lot more to
cover i want you to really teach the
kids of the process a little bit and i
think it'll be fun to really tap into
the learnings of a project
your in my opinion why this is important
is one of the most significant projects
in real life events that's adding the
killer app which is the lifetime pass
to me this is the most
one of the most interesting like the the
lifetime pass against something that's
already amazing me doing a three-year
pass for v-con nobody ever went to vcon
there is no [ __ ] v-con like nobody
knew if i could do it well or not or
what have you
rolling loud is [ __ ] rolling loud
it's already known everyone knows what
the [ __ ] it is and so i think
the educated even the people that are
hot like i think about the people that
are hardcore rolling loud who are like
yo [ __ ] nfts it's a scam they're buying
this yeah and that's because the utility
is the punch line yep
exactly if this was a qr code or a piece
of [ __ ] paper or a booklet or a
[ __ ]
app they buy it the fact that just
happens to be an nft like it's going to
be irrelevant it's the lifetime pass
period and that was by back in the day
everyone's like gary who's going to buy
wine on the internet back in 96 when all
of you were kids everyone's like this is
so stupid why are you doing this like
who's going to buy wine on the internet
when you can go to the store and buy it
and my answer was everyone mm-hmm
who's going to buy nfts everyone because
it's a utility
it's a better ledger
because it's also an asset if it was
just an app with a qr code when i got
tired of rolling loud
and let's say i just stopped liking that
kind of music it happens random ass [ __ ]
or i'm broke or or i'm super wealthy and
i don't [ __ ] want to do [ __ ] like
that who the [ __ ] knows why or i'm
settling down or i moved somewhere in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and i
don't want to travel
the fact that it's an asset if it's a qr
code
it's expiring on you right if it's an
nft you're selling it yep when are
people gonna understand this [ __ ] the
[ __ ] the matter with you all that's
the best part is you when you're done
with it you can flip it hey you could
buy five of them keep one for yourself
flip the other four you know it's like i
don't care i do you see what people do
in these other communities capitalism
you're an entrepreneur it is what it is
so anyway
appreciate you appreciate you good luck
thank you
everybody please check it out i think
this is something that you got to look
at this because even if you don't [ __ ]
with this music you're like [ __ ]
mumble rap i don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
cool you know cool pay attention to it
because when your [ __ ] comes up
the country one or the [ __ ] edm one
or whatever or like something else horse
racing or dinner series what the [ __ ]
it's all coming the real [ __ ] that does
a does it big globally is going to add
these lifetime killer app nfts and
they're going to really matter this is
the first one i'm excited about to
really watch how it plays out um not
because i love t because because i love
a lot of people because it's the first
one of a significant one that went to
the jugular the lifetime pass so it's
gonna be interesting to watch we'll all
learn a lot from it good luck to you
guys thank you and we'll talk appreciate
you
at loud punks nft at rolling loud
awesome